>> We are smustard.com and we write plug-ins
for a SketchUp. Our motivation really is to
train and help people reduce the repetitive
tasks in 3D modeling and to just simplify
complex tasks so that SketchUp becomes more
user friendly and more accessible to more
people.
>> So, how did you come to choose SketchUp?
Can you tell us a little bit about how you
come to this technical decision?
>> Okay. There are a lot of 3D modelers available
of the increasing levels of difficulty. One
of the benefits of SketchUp is it's accessible
to a lot of people. It's easy to learn, easy
to use, very powerful for the simplicity that
it gives on the front end. And so, it is actually
a professional decision originally to use
SketchUp where I work, and from there when
they released the Ruby API that just to open
the opportunity to customize and enhance SketchUp.
>> Okay. So, as a developers, we do evaluate
and to share worse stories and lessons on
technical challenges. Can you tell us about
one particular or difficult period of development
on it that you faced and how you approach
this difficult challenge?
>> One of the difficulties is that the API
has grown over time. And initially, there
are a lot of things that we would need to
do to create workarounds for missing parts
of the API. Since it was originally released,
it has improved significantly and that's helped
our developers to be able to do more things
with finding the workarounds for the things
that weren't available at that time was one
of the greater challenges, so.
>> So, can you tell me about the top three
or four things that you like about did all
the things for SketchUp?
>> One of the big improvements and one of
the things I really like is the ability to
use observers which tie directly into the
SketchUp core and report back any changes
in the model, or any changes to settings in
the model so that we can have instant feedback
and then respond to that. One example would
be a plug-in called NightSky which uses the
shadow and time of day settings that are native
to SketchUp, and uses an observer to query
those and as a user changes the settings or
the time of day you will change the sky to
reflect the time of day. So, you go from sunrise
to an afternoon sky to a sunset kind of sky.
So, that's one of the great things enhancements
that was added to the API was the observers,
so.
>> And then, what are some things you'd like
to see added to the API?
>> Support for more objects. Right now there's
no access to the dimension objects in SketchUp
and so if we could get access to those that
would really open up a whole new field of
development.
>> And then for the last question now, what
do you think is the future of 3D?
>> The future of 3D is just wide open. It's
amazing what SketchUp has done in making 3D
available to a lot of people, a lot of companies
that might not otherwise afford it. It can
turn small companies into big players because
it helps even out the field where 3D used
to the domain of very large companies that
have large I.T. departments. Now, two or three
or four person, architecture or engineering
firm can leverage SketchUp to help them present
to the client the things that they need to
see and really get their foot in the door
and make headway in their marketing.